[Music]
look at that this is actually a
depiction of a swan but what do you see
what do you feel I feel you don't live
here Ronnie she could stay here but I
can't get a dog she's my sister there's
a difference yeah there's a difference
you can have sex in front of a dog
today's a big day for Anna they're doing
one of those big
auctions if I want to work at a top Art
Gallery I got to get a good
recommendation and there is no better
recommendation than Claire DuPont
good morning everyone Irwin's clients
are about to walk through that door and
I will not allow them to see anything
less than Perfection you what's that
massive oil spill on the back of your
shirt it's not like we work for a
sociopathic perfectionist or anything oh
God hello it's Claire your boss I need
an extra assistant I just got invited to
go to London with Claire
Dupont you're not on this flight I put
you on one that leaves in 4 hours an
economy
you've just been upgraded first
class I'm William what brings you to
London our London branch has called in
the director of the New York office wow
you seem a bit young to be the director
yeah the youngest director in company
history if you're not too busy being a
Swanky art director I would love to take
you out I lied to him about so many
things you are here for work not for
play I got you the reservation tickets
for this
evening you going to invite me inside
excuse me what happened to your manners
down T
ABI mom she's a director of an auction
house in New
York I would like you in charge of my
auction I'm going to do it I'm jealous
of your Hannah Montana
lifestyle Sant us a word
please you're a New Yorker and being a
New Yorker means that you fight every
single
day Rocky bbo said that isn't he from
Philly he moved there from
[Music]
Brooklyn I was fully dreading coming to
this
wedding until you showed
up
could I get a cranberry juice with
ice and vodka when I first saw you I
thought that we should have sex in the
Cod
closet
yeah wait hold on I am kind of in a
weird place yeah you're in a beach club
coat closet you think that we could just
talk for a
minute romantic humiliations it's my
specialty I don't care the first person
to ever go down on me we just going to
steamroll right on through I came in my
own
eye okay go
on I've had too many girlfriends over
the past couple years I can't figure it
out yeah we've all been there tell me
what I'll give you some of this pie if
you tell me more about your
[Music]
past it's not like I don't come with my
own complications we're engaged
oh
wait you were
engaged lasted 13 days impressive that
is incredibly insulting I Ser what you
mean will you walk me to the train
station I actually have class no you
don't I like this J she's really hot I
know just wish I would have ended things
more
gracefully you ever see her
again this would never work you are
someone who cannot be counted on you've
run out on every guy you've ever been
with I'm a mess and I don't have any
answers but maybe you and I could figure
it out
together usually I feel so alone in my
memories but it's different with
you I'm happy to tell you a few more
embarrassing stories about my love life
well I promise not to laugh [__] I
promise not to laugh
much you ever change your mind
[Music]
on three big breath in
2 Waverly hi Auntie what are you doing
here I haven't had time off since med
school so now is my chance before I
started my
residency I haven't told my
[Music]
parents you made it hi you're Rachel's
neighbor I'm I'm Blake nice to meet
[Music]
you she
okay are you okay I'm okay are you okay
me morning hi you can't swim huh I kind
of missed that as a kid I could teach
you why are you doing this like spending
time with you I hate thinking all the
years SP without knowing you and weit
tell me about your parents I hav been do
them in 4 years they make sure I have
everything that I need but they don't
really know
me are you looking at me
no I kind of have feelings for Blake no
kidding here you are having the best
summer of your life going after a boy
you like I think I see love birs she's
thinking about moving here it's just so
rain hi Mom Dr Wong squeeze you into his
research team this is for your future my
parents want me in Toronto I'm not
normally very
impulsive where can we just stay in that
[Music]
moment B you lied to us I want to stay
here with you but I do want to be a
doctor I don't have to act like this is
anything more than Summer
Fling this time you ask yourself what
you want to do I don't want the summer
to end you have to make yourself known
in this life not for anyone
else but for
[Music]
you this is a story about me Leo and T
how is the shop doing well it
is it seems like you are making
something of yourself in my Z it's a
Chinese tradition to have your fortune T
before big
[Music]
event we can celebrate Le success as
well I'm in
control five days Jesus has answered my
[Music]
prayer we each pick one date and I
already have the perfect man in mind I
have a $50 bet on my date Dad I'm not
some slot machine Le yeah don't say
[__] come you will be my public facing
wife wait
what what she needs is someone who is
loyal yeah you have to try it what did
you say this one again oh my
[Applause]
gosh oh my
gosh my God something died oh and they
were buried in your
mouth Richard it's good to see you mhm
oh this is a nightmare not meeting
anyone
new Grandma I know what you're going to
say suck it up and get back out
there dating is just a numbers game and
your number happens to be
five in 6 months we'll begin trying for
children Three Sons
minimum my grandma told me to follow my
dreams your feeling I'm a
failure even though I'm still prettier
it's all I
[Music]
have why is this the best date so far if
you want to do some over the pan stuff
we good I was dreading it
too what's your name CYO sweet I'm Mr
Miller I'm assuming that you got one of
these before I read the whole list well
there's 12 books on that list Bary
har
always what is an
adult I'm
18 languishing in the Wilds of nowhere
Tennessee break C don't you get scared
walking through those woods I'm the
scariest thing in
there never knew I could be
speechless I want you to write a short
story in the style of your favorite
author are you offering me special
treatment Mr Miller well
uh John here is prepping her to be his
Transcendent is she pretty oh she's
talented damn even worse what are you
bring about I've been inspired have had
no achievement make him love you I set
fire to the
don't know she's open her mouth to say
[Music]
something but the words fell
away why did you write this this is
inappropriate write what you know is
what you said if you don't readiz this
I'll have to fail
you I dare
you it's like he's been living in
grayscale and you're the first thing
he's ever seen in
color you are the adult show some
responsibility you my student and I'm
your teach you that's
all if she can convince them that
something happened between us I can lose
my job it's not all you could lose you
going to ruin his life burn it down it
down
it
in your own words how did it start said
good
K Titanic me what Titanic me oh my God
this is so
cringe lift my arms I've seen the movie
have
you going to do the line it's king of
the world you're king of the world Jack
I'm flying a it's the cutest thing I've
ever seen are they doing
Titanic are they watching yep are they
buying
it hey head of the wedding of my sister
yes I am where's your fiance wait is
this him wow you are a child hey I'm Ben
I was her hall pass on your
break what
the I could never be with someone like
him girl's a
disaster those two going to ruin our
wedding sorry I'm
no way honey look who's here who is this
my ex Jonathan my parents have been
trying to get us back together he like a
son to us maybe we should just tell
everyone work together what it would
solve that problem for me and you
clearly want Margaret she sees here with
me she wants what she can have let's do
it we're coming we're coming you owe
[Music]
a you and Ben are
serious I know what you're thinking he's
much older they weren't right probably
thinking I'm 27 early
[Music]
28s nobody believes us let's just be eff
permission to put my hand on your
granted right okay not in circles it's
not a magic lamp are they watching is it
working God damn it wait I feel
something what the what the where are
they what the one might be in you I'm
good it's probably a better way to check
than what I did it's a bad idea
right okay they're gone show's over oh
my
God oh my God it looks like they're
going full Titanic I love the commitment
[__] it it's
fine you taught your Dad
recently why
give us a
[Music]
call so where did you appear
from
Oklahoma I've never been Anywhere But
Here what what are you doing with that
big
girl
get a lot of crazy ass foreigners
mostly how's it going
guys this here's Jackie hi she needs a
job say she'll do anything yeah you like
guns not really what the [__] you doing
here
then a bit more powerful than a punch
huh [__] yeah call me when it's
done what is this
place huh you don't
understand get back in the car
run they found a
body looks like you've got your hands
full don't regret
this we'll just need to fight
back I'm going to tell them everything
you ever did FBI open up are you
threatening
me yep
that was really stupid
honey never for
[Music]
okay
are you hot for
any Lisa does he have more of a
basketball b or a football B he doesn't
play
sports my Tender Is grave I talk to him
I wish I was been
you that's really weird
[Music]
Lisa
you hear that I'm sure it's the girl
next door she's very
odd your
hand I can't believe you're here do you
like music I have the Cure oh not that
kind of cure they can't make you better
I mean they can but like emotionally no
don't cry your tears to well so
bad send it back you need a
friend I love it it's not really my
style when you're in doubt LSA looks
good she could probably even do pageants
if she had
Congeniality your daughter has a little
psycho i' open my glorious home to an
ungrateful
little I want to help
Taffy says it's a waste of time to try
and fix
a he better just accept a guy fall
that's so cute got I have an idea there
are bad people out there come on Le it
it'll feel
good that hand is going to do terrible
things you are being admitted impatient
lock down I to
walk
all I could get the clink for life or
the electric chair but I don't want to
die a
virgin you know anything about The
Disappearance of a
student I'm not making any more
comments you can talk to my lawyer
really hope this goth phase in soon need
a
[Music]
United
Nations did you give me
this
[Music]
oh fore
spee where
for
Fore
spee
for
[Music]
nice
[Applause]
[Music]
foree
[Applause]
for
[Music]
spee
speee
[Music]
[Applause]
fore
for
spe
hi what's your name prisilla Boer you
like Elvis
Presley of course who
doesn't one are the kids must been to
these days Bobby Darren Fabian and you
[Music]
just what is the intent here Mr presy
you got women throwing themselves at you
why my daughter well Sarah I happen to
be very fun of your
daughter she's much more mature than her
age
21 22 that's
22 you don't have to worry
[Applause]
anybody black hair and more eye
makeup I don't know if I like it
what do you mean you don't know if
you're lying
yet he's not like you
[Applause]
[Music]
imagine you know there's a lot of rumors
about
you is there something you're
hiding I don't have a goddamn thing to
[Music]
hide I need a woman who understands that
things like this might happen are you
going to be here or not
[Music]
I want a life of my
own let's rob a do what
now they cannot get
away
once upon a time I was just a wee boy
worked at the post
office done asked you for 6 months to
chop that freaking yeti off your head
get it
gone D girl of my dreams marmal you
going to show me around or
what from then on we was
[Music]
Inseparable my my mom they raise the
price of her medicine overnight I say
when the system fails you create your
own damn
system half a million dollar on Capo we
got to take this
serious oh God Dam dear sweet Lord we
are
scared it's time we start kick him back
get him the
CL
baby I was just
playing I ain't no
criminal I've been chasing her for 2
years hey you see Mama's peels she's
just as much my mama now too
stop can't tell if you're being
[Music]
honest
[Applause]
[Music]
it's me and you against the whole wide
world that was class sorry that was my
fault are you okay you just had Zach
McLaren's ball in your face what's his
GPA you have any books on battle toads
you know video games are now the leading
caus the divorce Could you actually
order me a book on that really no
sarcasm is frequently an attempt to
deflect one's ignorance so being to know
it all oh wait you forgot your credit
card oh my God what's up heck get a car
now he has a concussion and he thinks it
him his girlfriend thank God it's you oh
oh righty he is dating as always what
other zoee he's either dead or he's dumb
to me honestly I'm not sure which is
worse make sure Zach takes it easy his
symptoms could get worse what do I do
you don't want him getting worse pretend
to be the other Zoe you've been dating 2
or 3 weeks now
right
Yep this is Zach's cousin miles he's in
grad school at MIT oh my God a match for
Zoe I cost the accident and now I'm
going to flirt with an Amnesia patient's
cousin we're all going to go skiing in
the mountains this weekend you want to
go with us strip of land seven letters
CHR how did you know that well done you
two should we H slops yeah we
shall it's confusing I'm enjoying
getting to know you over again go you a
swing at
life you and Zach do you really think
it's you're a good match like we are
it's
complicated we need to tell him the
truth we have to go after what you want
and be
brave oh my God you're just giving me
romcom advice now no it's so
[Music]
fun so what did you do did you have fun
what didn't we do excuse me All PG-13
[Music]
okay I don't understand why you have to
formally inv your parents you know
they're coming the invites here I love
that she went with antique Sage is that
the more expensive one our one and only
daughter is getting there do not talk to
me about money right now I still think
they should have
justo Marshall you think I should give
him a plus one he's your man of Honor if
he's single he'll come stag otherwise
he'll bring someone but what if he
brings Marie welcome to Tampa lizard
you're getting married can you believe
it
surprise this place is perfect no I I'm
too dignified of a man to be on a beach
I specifically wrote plus one anyone but
Marie James I mean I just don't
understand how someone else can book the
bridal sleep during someone else's
wedding it's me I'm the bride there a
week can trade no marshmallow he said we
can have the better room are you that
woman is a disaster I have to do special
brownies for my sister just bake as much
pot in the batter as possible pot the
most important day of our lives and you
were asked to bring anyone anyone except
Marie oh God I can't believe you just
stole a trolley what are you doing with
my wedding dress on get this party
started better get
a what did you put in those
brownies he somebody need a
epip we should really respect
nature on my hand it's on my
hand get the briding Grom raise your
glasses to the briding groom y'all
should heo
[Music]
pressure is all right Gary it's
perfect is there any area in particular
you want me to focus on today um Gary
how many guys have you done this with
you're the first guy that I've ever been
intimate with I had a wife she left I
really don't know what to say I mean
words of affirmation is not my love
language it's more
like I've been alive nearly half a
century and I haven't actually lived
even a second of it Gary I'm going to
help you let's find someone for you oh
my God there's so many hot guys I think
that this might just be too much too
late he's already on his way wait
what hello what sup bro just want to get
in and get out oh you can get in all
right it's a gorgeous Landing what are
you doing I'm calling 911 Gary no
accidents happened it was your first
night being gay did you really think you
were going to make any mistakes [__] he
BL through the AR that's Mountain
Ashwood it's really porous oh my God
you're so
gay are you in C no wait are you no good
cuz the dark web's built on trust come
on is this what it's like this is what
it's like I am like human poppers I open
anyone up I'm really glad I met
you even if multiple people are dead
because of it dripping diamonds a
thousand eyes watching Silence as we get
high
Church girls know how to
kneel where are you
going I am a cool hot zti where'd you
kill him oh we outside you move the body
just in the closet you guys ever seen
gong girl just aart with B stick
Gary they spent what a trillion dollarss
trying to get one dude back from Mars if
you get the opportunity to bring back
Matt Damon I just don't think we should
wait around and be saved you know you
really don't think they're sending
anybody to save us I
[Music]
mean in case you haven't noticed we're
doomed to spend the rest of our
miserable lives on this ship maybe we
should do it do what
it we're not attracted now but we would
emotionally attach you mean fall in love
what if this awesome thing we have going
on gets ruined people are meant to be
together oh sorry is this is this on
okay
lame we're both married I'm sure being a
drift in space gives you a hard
[Music]
pass you know what you want to watch
tonight alien never seen
it why then hell did we watch that
[Music]
movie